have you ever thought about how like
social media changes how we interact I
was like watching like high schoolers
from like like videos of high schoolers
from like 20 years ago I'm like wow I
don't even know what the world was like
without smartphones
yeah like I like they came for me and
like when I was in eighth grade right
like I mean I I just remember like I
remember being in Middle School the [__]
was like yeah we didn't have any phones
until like I'd say like maybe the end of
my sixth grade year and people started
getting flip phones and stuff like that
and then basically it was a girl who got
the phones first and every guy ran to
get a phone because the moment you got a
phone you got to get their number it was
like there was like you know when
Instagram first launch everyone could
get a super amount of followers it was
that same [__] so I remember like in my
middle school as soon as you got a phone
every girl would just give you their
number and stuff like you're like [__]
yeah dude and then and then you know but
that was kind of the advantage it was
really like girls who like at least from
what I've seen that like made everyone
want to get phones basically
classic we just spend money spend money
we just spend us yeah we're like Dad
but but yeah we've grown softer because
of social media we've gained a lot
because of social media but we've also
been hurt a lot I mean relationships I
mean we like it it is kind of weird we
shouldn't actually know like the rich
have always been Rich they've always
done the [__] [__] orgies or whatever
the [__] they're doing degeneracy and
good things and bad things right living
in these great amazing homes but not
nine times out of ten you would have
never seen it or you would have seen a
little bit and that's it it but it's
being shown in your face every single
[__] day you have these 21 year olds
they're showing off they have all this
[__] money and like dude half half
these 21 year olds and Dubai are [__]
broken their line they're they're
selling you a drop a Drop Shipping
course and stuff and very few of them
are making money on that and stuff like
that and like but you could you could
right right well and the other thing is
I was talking to this um older woman
about this um I think she's like my Uber
driver and she was like she was saying
how back in the day like you would watch
the music awards or whatever and you
would realize like that's not real life
yeah the problem with women now is like
we think that though those men are like
real life because a lot of times like
you know average chicks have access to
them yeah or like even like that
lifestyle yeah but she was like we knew
that like okay you turn on the TV you go
to that event but that's not real but
like now it's like we we almost think
this stuff is is real yeah but that's
what's really screwed up the like the
dating Market as well you know the whole
thing this in Rollo wrote his essay
about this several years ago talking
about the global dating Marketplace
because now like you said theoretically
you know an average to middling sort of
sort of girl if she's you know
relatively cute can get dudes from like
Miami or bloody I don't know the south
of France or whatever like small towns
in Dubai yeah dming her and all of that
and and even if she doesn't take up
those opportunities because not
everyone's obviously going to it's going
to skew her perception of her value
within the dating market so you know Joe
who works down the local garage is
suddenly going to seem less attractive
to her you know because she's looking at
these dudes with like the 12-pack and
everything else so unless you have like
really strong Day game or something like
our night game most some of the best
chicks are just they're not even in your
area anymore they they're [__] yeah
and I realized too I was like Wow and
even if there is a girl that maybe like
hasn't slept around like or like is
really attractive like all the things
that guys look for I'm like the line for
her is gonna be so long and it almost
ruins us having too many choices yeah
because there's a girl that went on our
show and she was like a 21 year old like
really attractive virgin and I was like
Wow and I was just thinking from her
point of view I'm like the line is just
gonna be so long how do you like pick
one
it's sort of like that reverse Meme and
stuff like that one there's some chick
getting [__] and there's like a line
and there's one dude in a suit yeah
you're trying to get the application
here but I mean that is crazy but that
is the thing I mean like uh I can't
remember who said this and stuff but if
a woman would just stay a virgin till 24
[__] you should get billionaires she can
get all this stuff and maybe a little
bit Tad much but you know or a
supermodel could you know Waits that
long and stuff what is the millionaire
yeah at least a millionaire or something
like that but you or just but it's that
it's that sort of thing you know it's
um and this all comes down to money
scarcity you know game it's it's there's
so much [__] and like
I really feel like most guys never would
I mean dude the amount of stuff you got
to learn as a guy and a girl is insane
and then on top of that like it's kind
of [__] up like when you're you're
when you're really young to learn I mean
[Laughter]
yeah
I mean like it's like don't it's like
don't be a [__] and we're like we can't
do that
[__]
you know I mean I always say this to
anyone on the 24 is [__] right but
and I don't mean that in the worst way
but it's true but I mean you got to take
a look alert yeah you've got a lot to
learn right you got life lessons to
learn and guys are super stupid I mean
we're super dumb and those guys in their
40s are [__] still but like you know
we have time to kind of grow up and on
top of that I mean yeah if guys could
just get all the places they want they
would take it right away and right away
but for women like you kind of have the
cookie already and but you're dumb still
yeah well well and I realized too like
we're also like kind of the equivalent
of like porn addicts walking around
because we get so much attention
oh yeah I mean yeah because it's like
we're all like and especially just doing
the show I'm like we all say like the
same exact arguments to each other and
we all just like regurgitate the same
[__] we see on social media and like and
I was just like we're basically just
like these like porn addicted women but
like social media addicted walking
around right yeah because they want to
be it's like the magazine right like
back in the day when you're watching
like Sports Illustrated you're like oh I
want to be like that girl right and that
was like something to attain to because
you have the media making that something
bigger than what it is yeah and now we
have social media doing that for
Facebook was the first time right you're
like I know that [__] from high
school does not have that great of a
life but he you know or she like
basically paints a fantasy and yeah
that's now become like the norm like if
you don't lie about your life on social
media like you're [__] up well people
won't click on it yeah or even like
verb I remember like the last time I
went out with like my volleyball team I
was just like why do we have to film
every
why do we or even like you just go to a
concert all the like I went
um oh like not being in the moment well
it's like I went to
um the the weekend they they invited
like my whole team to like go like watch
the show I don't even really know much
about the weekend but the concert was
kind of satanic I was like on Earth
I was like well on our sets of stuff on
the stage but it was so crazy because we
were in like the part where like the
people that were like invited to it you
know what I'm saying so it's a lot of
like hot chicks like and these are some
I was like wow these are the real nines
and tens I've never really seen them
before
and I was like oh okay but yeah and it
was like they were all just on their
phones like recording the whole time and
you know like I I do this video stuff so
sometimes I'm like I do not like want to
be recorded but it's like women were
just out recording everything like all
the time I know men like some men too
but it is not the same yeah for business
they're not doing it for anything I
think it's really attention I think it's
quite hard for dudes I mean I mean even
even for myself you know if you put
stuff on the internet and stuff like
that but to remind myself to film stuff
and to take photographs I mean it's just
you just like yeah whatever it's not a
second whereas you go out with a girl
and she'll be filming everything you
know I should be getting oh just just
take a different angle of me and they'll
be videoing stuff and putting it on a
social media you know it's just it's
nuts yeah
regardless of the size of their account
girls from very small accounts to Big
accounts you know they're just all doing
it the whole time yeah and they're like
oh you know just go and kneel in the
sewer and get that right yeah
[__] off you know
because we see here in Vegas you see
this boy it's not it's nothing bad with
a boyfriend or something or her husband
taking a picture of the wife the problem
is is like when you see these dudes like
getting in the gutter
like I mean it's like they're they're
just basically she dated a [__] she's
like she might as well just go date a
[__] photographer
and she's just using this group because
like half the time you're you're over
there advertising you're [__] female
so why you have why is she yeah why is
she even on social media and the first
like I can understand maybe a [__]
Facebook or some [__] right because
all my grandmas are on there right now
but but like um but you know why I mean
why is your girl advertising herself so
she can get that bag ditch him and then
you know
come on that was like the wheel that was
oh my gosh that was like a red pill when
I was like learning about the stuff I
was like wow we're like why we can't
even tell the difference between wives
and mothers they look the same as single
chicks it's like okay before it's like
you kind of know you move different when
you're a mom and a wife you know you're
not gonna you kind of expect all right
when they're young they dress a little
[__] you know you kind of you know
your wife might have worn like a short
skirt back in the day but now it's like
but then it was like when you get
married you cover up now you're the
Virgin Mary you're a nun you don't know
anything yeah but it's like
you can't even tell the difference like
you have Kiki Palmer well a Mother
wearing a thong to a concert I'm like it
like you know society's bad when you
can't tell the difference and then if
you point that out you're misogynistic
or the bad guy or what about you Pearl
or it's like all right you guys I think
this is getting bad like I think this is
not yeah I was like maybe this is like
not the best Direction
it's just it it just always fascinates
me though the amount of power an
attractive young woman has got like and
even economic power it's just incredible
like you could like on Instagram you
could literally like
basically you're a hot chick you're
slimy or a hot chick that that's it 700
000 followers you know brand deals
people flying you out to places it's
just amazing and I mean it for women it
must be if you're either you're in that
position that must be incredibly
addictive because you you've got that
lifestyle you've got those opportunities
but even if you're not but you're you
know you've got a smaller account but
you're thinking well if I play it right
I could get up there I mean it's it's no
wonder that like dating is getting
screwed it's no wonder that Society is
changing right you know because
particularly these young women they get
they get given the keys to the kingdom
don't they right if they're attractive
if they're attractive which is great and
they can have fun for it for a period of
time but you know then then what happens
you know the metaverse happens and all
of a sudden there's a 40 year old dudes
selling you they're AI girls
well it's like we trade a lifetime of
happiness for like 10 years not only
fans yeah
remember I'm gonna look it up after the
show but only five percent of women are
still practicing like um I think it was
the study was done with hookers but it's
either after the age of 35 or 45
are left oh so oh so they get rolled out
after at 30 and there's and then they're
just living well I think it's older than
30. okay I don't know what because I was
thinking maybe they'll because I was
thinking what are they gonna do with us
older women like when we're single
childless and like and I was like maybe
they'll legalize prostitution I would
hurt the market
well but then then I found out
um yeah they yeah men don't obviously
want to bang old chicks they're only
five percent stay past the age or three
they're 35 or five I think it's 40. I
think it's 40. stay where like just keep
practicing
all right out of work yeah yeah and then
most I mean let's before like most only
fans models yeah don't even make any
money at all it's really like the one
percent of like these chicks actually
make any money always managed by men
were so stupid we can't even sell
sexuality that is the one
I know there's exceptions to every rule
but as a group guys we're dummies
it's the one-liners at the beginning of
the show
that always surprised me about the whole
only fans Model Management like model
though you know the place you're doing
in the various other people it's a bit
like well can't these girls like they're
the ones with the goods come they sell
it themselves they're like no no we do
all the back end stuff and everything
it's like well yeah but surely I mean is
it it's only worth two hours a day or
they're what will their work one day a
week because that's enough money
um and then it's like cool the rest of
my free time and they always say like my
free time I think I think even like um
like you said only fans girls I mean
obviously not you know a fraction of
them are making the really big money but
there's opportunities I mean I've
personally met women not only fans but
with small Instagram accounts who are
getting who are doing overseas trips so
they're getting flown around by people
like they're in Sugar Arrangements you
know they're getting so they're not it's
not it's a very soft form of
hoeing if you like it yeah you know it's
not like they're getting a lot of sums
of money but they're certainly getting
trips they're certainly getting
advantages off of you know and these
aren't girls with massive following so
it's just incredible the amount of
people most women 80 of women are
hooking for trips they're not even
hooking for money they just want the
picture that they're in [__] Cancun
or they're out in Dubai they're not even
getting paid money like you you did all
that travel you get a g congratulations
right and like I mean just I mean and
just because um somebody in the chat the
chat's kind of go crazy about this and
stuff
obviously there's nothing wrong with
recording yourself with your kids you
should take as many pictures as with
your kids that's beautiful of course but
what we're talking about is like all
these like is it if you take a picture
in a little video cool but it shouldn't
be like that should be like five seconds
or five minutes of whatever you're doing
and then you're the phone's away and
you're and you're with the people you're
talking to and stuff right unless you
have like a business or something of
course right